today on the matt wall show republicans
are trying to appease the left
as usual this time with police reform
measures but i have an idea for
different reforms that we could
make our priority and should make our
priority before we talk about reforming
the police
also five headlines including the
michigan prosecutor um
who still has not arrested or charged
the man who brutally assaulted a macy's
employee
on camera uh still hasn't done it is
according to him is considering not
charging him at all we'll play that clip
for you
and we'll also discuss a video of a
white protester trying to explain
racism lecturing about racism to a group
of black police officers it doesn't go
very well for her as you might imagine
all of that coming up so republicans in
the senate
have come up with a police reform bill
the bill has been blocked by democrats
not only blocked
by democrats but nancy pelosi infamously
said that the bill is murder it is
murder republicans are trying to get
away with murder with this bill they're
trying to get away specifically with the
murder of george floyd
with their police reform bill that's
what she said
how is this bill murdering george floyd
who is of course already dead and who
died in a
democrat-run city i mean how could you
possibly blame the murder of george
floyd on
senate republicans when he died in a
democrat-run city at the hands of one
single police officer
who knows but she's not apologizing for
the comment
when you were speaking yesterday you
said that republicans are quote trying
to get away with murder actually the
murder
of george floyd senate republicans are
demanding an apology for that statement
will you apologize
absolutely positively not uh the fact
is people say i think you frankly in the
press have given them
far too much credit for a bill that does
nothing
they're saying well you have your bills
they have theirs yeah our bill does
something
there's doesn't matter does tim scott
work in a good face i guess
i'm sorry well we would have does tim
scott working in good faith is this a
good starting point
i'm talking about mitch mcconnell now
what does this murderous bill actually
do
or what is it intended to do anyway
reading now from an npr report which for
the most part appears to be relatively
fair surprisingly
it says the legislation will increase
federal reporting requirements for use
of force no knock warrants
it also increases penalties for false
police reports
it seeks to encourage chokehold bans
through this added transparency and by
withholding funding for units without
bans on chokeholds except
with deadly forces authorized the effort
also looks to
up use of body police body cameras with
grant programs and in turn penalties for
failing to use the cameras
it creates a database of police
disciplinary records for law enforcement
departments
to use their hiring practices it makes
lynching a federal crime which is linked
to an effort that passed in the house
but has recently stalled in the senate
it directs the justice department to
develop and provide training
on de-escalation tactics and implement
duty to intervene
uh policies that's what democrats are
blocking
and uh there's we'll talk about all the
specifics here
making lynching a federal crime what's
the point of that
it's when is the last time we
we actually have a verified case of
somebody being lynched in this country
and you know on in the extremely
extremely extremely rare
occasion that it does happen if it does
happen
why would that form of murder be a
federal crime when any
so if you if you lynch somebody it's a
federal crime but if you just shoot them
in the head it's not
uh why would we be doing that well this
is about of course there's no reason for
it it's absurd the whole thing's absurd
but this is republicans just trying to
appease the left and give them what they
want even if it doesn't make any sense
but democrats are blocking it
republicans are shocked and scandalized
that the bloc the bill is being blocked
here's senator tim scott reacting
in detroit
minneapolis los angeles philadelphia
all these cities could have banned
chokeholds themselves
they could have increased the police
reporting themselves they could have
more data information
themselves they could have de-escalation
training themselves they could have duty
to intervene
themselves minneapolis as well
all these communities have been run by
democrats
for decades
decades what is the roi
for the poorest people in this nation
and i don't blame them
i blame an elite political class with
billions of dollars to do whatever they
want to do and look at the results
for the poorest most vulnerable people
in our nation
i'm willing to compete for their vote
are you
but democrats are even more shocked and
scandalized
so it's a competition who can be the
most shocked and scandalized democrats
are even more
which um camilla harris says that she's
shocked and scandalized because the bill
is hollow and political and she of
course knows something about being
hollow and political
watch we're here because
mitch mcconnell has put up a bill
challenging us to either
comply with his political game that is
about obstructing
the united states senate's ability to
actually do something
or to to play a game with him
which is only about covering his
political
concerns and not about the real concerns
that the american people have
about the realities of two systems of
justice in america
and we're not going to play that game
and we're not going to be played
the truth as we know it is that people
by the
thousands are marching in the streets of
america
of every race every age and gender
in every geographic location in all the
50 states
unified demanding
we act demanding
that finally something is actually done
and we have it in our power
to actually do something and back and
forth we go but you know something
i'm happy that this bill was blocked by
democrats
i really am and i want to tell you why
and i'll do that in just a second but
first
today's show is brought to you by rad
power bikes listen
this is a great way if you if you if you
want to get out and about
and finally you know start emerging from
your home again if you've been
locked down for so long electric bikes
are a great way to do it
convenient fun whether you want a new
way to commute or just get around town
get around the city out in nature
whatever it is even if you have your
kids in tow
okay you've got to try rad power bikes
it's a cross between a traditional bike
and a moped but it doesn't require a
special driver's license you don't have
to worry about all that red tape
you can go up to 20 miles per hour
without pedaling um and you can get out
about without getting sweaty
which is a for for those of us who are
in the the sweat
for those of us who tend to get
especially sweaty who are in the sweaty
community
um yes we do have our own community this
is this is also great as well
they're great for commuting getting out
on the trail hauling groceries you
transport your kids on the back
uh whatever you need it for and also by
the way dedicated us-based customer
support
seven days a week to answer any
questions or concerns so they're there
for you
they're gonna answer your questions
makes a perfect gift for someone who
loves being active
and outdoors rad power bikes offers
flexible financing for as low as zero
percent apr right now as a limited time
offer
um get a free accessory with the
purchase of a bike that's right get a
free gift of up to a hundred dollars
in value and free shipping to the lower
48 states to get this special offer text
the word bike
to 64 000 that's bike to 64 000. text
bike
bike to 64 000.
all right dems are blocking the bill i'm
happy they did here's why uh two reasons
one
i'm an optimist at heart cheerful
optimist which you know this about me
okay i see everything through rosie
rosie tinted glasses
and so i i hope
that finally finally
finally republicans will learn
that you will never ever win by trying
to suck up to
and appease the left no matter what you
do
no matter what it won't be enough
there is no reason to ever do anything
because you think that it will make them
feel good
or or you know you're trying not to
upset them
there's no reason to ever do anything
for those reasons
it'll never be enough republicans could
pass a bill
abolishing the police abolishing the
national anthem
mandating the removal of the statue of
liberty
which will be replaced by a 300-foot
statue of uh i don't know rupaul
deporting all white people to mars
whatever
and they'd still be told that it's it's
not only not enough
but it's so insufficient that it only
proves that republicans are literal
nazis
who sacrifice goats to idols of hitler
that are constructed out of
the bones of puppies
that's the way it always goes okay so
maybe republicans will learn that
probably not but that's my hope anyway
second reason
that i'm glad it's spot locked it's a
bad bill
it is just a bad bill i know it's a bad
bill because they're trying to pass it
for the reason just stated to appease
the left
when was any republican talking about
police reform
before say two months ago before george
floyd
there weren't very many republicans
putting this forward as the number one
item on their agenda were there
who in the republican party was calling
for that almost no one
they discovered this passion for police
reform because of the public outcry over
one particular case a case
that we have no reason to think has
anything to do with bad policy or bad
policing strategies
people are so emotional that you you we
we can't stop and be
and be reasonable about this and realize
that
it's nothing to do this had nothing to
do with a bad policy
this was the behavior of one cop who it
seems
may have had a personal issue with
george floyd because it seems like they
knew each other
though actually we still don't know a
whole lot about
we still to this point there's been a
lot there's been a lot of reaction
to put it mildly to george floyd and his
death
we still don't know almost anything
about what happened
do you realize that we don't know the
context we don't know what led up to it
we don't know
we to this point we have not seen body
cam footage
though it exists we have not seen dash
cam footage
though it exists why is that that's
that's a whole different question but
the point is that this bill is a
reaction to a high profile news event
and bill's passed as a reaction to
high-profile news event
events bills that seek to make new laws
and regulations based on the public
reaction
to something in the news are almost
always
bad they are almost always passed for
well camella harris said it hollow and
political reasons i actually agree with
her criticism
the only difference is that she forgot
to mention that she is also hollow and
political and her own police reform
efforts are the same so she was half
right anyway
do the police need to be reformed um
well again if you didn't think so two
months ago then you shouldn't think so
now there's no re
nothing has happened in the last two
months that should make you
uh that would have it should have
changed your mind about however you felt
about police reform
do i think that police should be well
sure any institution
especially a government institution can
stand to be reformed refined
that's a constant process that that
should always continue
um there are always problems to be
addressed
adaptations that need to be made uh
keeping up with the times and all that
kind of stuff
so yes but not like this
not under these circumstances not for
this reason
not passed down from the top from the
federal government
in a panic in reaction to voters who are
emotional and upset
for reasons that many of those voters
can't even articulate
these are quote unquote reforms that
need to be much more localized and
targeted and enacted with the input of
actual law enforcement officials
not empty suits in dc but here's the
real point for me
before we talk about police reform
before we get to that i think there are
other much more
pressing reforms that need to be made
and these are
the reforms that republicans if they had
any guts at all if they were worth
anything
if they weren't utterly worthless
useless spineless
jellyfish floating around barely able to
stand on their own two feet because
they're comprised of such weak
gelatinous material they would be
calling for
reforms that restore law and order in
the streets
and bring the criminals and terrorists
to justice that's what we need right now
that's what we need first and urgently
and don't tell me
that well this will help restore or
store law and order because this is what
the anarchists want and it it will it
will make them happy
and they'll go away no no they're
anarchists they're insurrectionists
they're nihilus okay they're they're
they're they're people that are
destroying
for the sake of it there's nothing you
can do they're not gonna say oh you know
what
republicans pass police reform guys
let's stop toppling the statue for a
minute
let's look over this bill we'll talk
about it and uh maybe it's good and
maybe we just go home
that's not going to happen that's not
ever going to happen
never there is nothing in a police
reform bill that will do
one single damned thing to stop
the uh spread of lawlessness and
anarchy across the country
so one example of a reform measure that
could be put in place
uh if you let's if you remember this
video watch it again
now that dirt bag who pushed
the 92 year old woman onto the ground
she hit her head against a fire hydrant
had been arrested anywhere from 60 or 60
to 100 times already
including sex crimes why not a reform
that gets monstrosities like that off of
the street for good
forever why not some reforms targeted at
preventing terrorists
from tearing down priceless monuments or
reforms enacting
stiffer penalties for people who
participate in riots
i could list dozens of more reforms that
could be enacted
that that could be made in the direction
of restoring order to our communities
and freeing us from the grip
of anarchists and insurrectionists and
all around scumbags who are trying to
destroy
society and if republicans had any sense
or any guts or any spine
that's what they would be doing instead
we get
police reform
instead we get them following the agenda
of the left
as always the left looks at what's
happening and they say this is
this is a sign we need police reform and
the stupid
useless republicans say you know what
you're right that's that's what we need
completely useless and the argument
for as long as i've been alive you know
for as long as i've been alive i've
known
that um oh sorry about that
for as long as i've been alive i've
known that the republicans are useless
but i've always been told that well
they're better than the democrats
so you just got to vote for them they're
better okay it's the best we can do
sorry just suck it up buttercup it's the
best we can do
is it i mean are they even better than
the democrats
how are they better it's the lines are
blurring so much
in what way democrats are doing nothing
to restore law and order
republicans are doing nothing they're
both doing nothing they're both focusing
on police reform
we're really going to get to a point i
think we're probably there already where
there just is
is really no substantive difference
between these two
groups of people um
[Music]
and i think arguably we've been there
and have been there for a long time all
right let's go to
news headlines number one over the last
several days i've been telling you about
this
apparently racially motivated hate crime
at a macy's in michigan
uh watch it again
[Music]
don't touch me don't touch me don't
touch me
quit touching me you don't
the important update on this story is
that there is no update
nothing has happened in this case it's
been 10 days nothing has happened no
charges the man seen
pummeling a macy's store manager in
broad daylight in the middle of the
store on video
has not been arrested has not been
charged with anything he brutally
assaulted someone
on camera we you know we see it he's the
guy's on the ground begging for mercy
getting pummeled
hasn't been arrested for it the
prosecutor david leighton
um hears his twitter by the way he
hasn't filed charges
he's still has not and he's actually
considering
not filing charges at all that's what he
said here he is right now we'll listen
to this
i would say to the president and anybody
else who has
an interest in this that i will make a
fair and just decision as to charging or
not
charging after i have all the
information the warrant request
only came in today the police reports
only came in today
and after we reviewed them we determined
that they're not complete yet we want
more information
so i would say to mr president give us
the time that we need
and we certainly would appreciate it if
you would send more resources
in to help us because genesee county is
not the most
wealthy county and our police
departments work very very hard our
prosecutor's office
works very very hard but it takes time
to get these right
we want to get it right so haste makes
waste
and we're going to make sure that we do
everything
so it's fair and just for all people
concerned
charging or not charging he's deciding
about
charging or not he is actually as of now
according to him
leaving open the possibility of not
charging a man with a crime
for pummeling another man while that man
is on the ground
begging him to stop he's saying
potentially in his eyes
that's not a crime
really what would make that not a crime
what information he said we're still
investigating
what what information could you possibly
discover in your investigation that
would make this not a crime
what could you possibly find out that's
what i want to know
what could have happened before this
that would make
what you saw on video okay
in the eyes of the law the assailant's
brother by the way who filmed it and
posted it
doesn't even claim that it was
self-defense
okay he doesn't even so the the people
responsible for
they're not even pretending that this
was legally justified
which which of course of course it's not
self a macy's store manager i very much
doubt would get into a fist fight with
random customers who are coming in the
door
but that isn't even being claimed anyway
the claim from the assailants
their defense is that the manager said
the n-word which he didn't that's
clearly a lie but even if he did
how would that change a single damned
thing in respect to criminal charges
you don't have the legal authority to
assault someone because they said a word
you don't like
so how would that make a difference he
also says uh
that i don't know i don't think it's in
the clip but he says that
they're looking at different footage and
they're looking at security camera
footage but unfortunately it doesn't
have audio
what do you need audio for who cares
what's being
said and uh the prosecutor says he needs
more resources
that trump should send him what
resources do you need
you have a video of it and you have a
public confession
from the assailants that they gave to
the media
admitting that they assaulted him and
saying that the only reason they did it
is that he said a word a bad word and
then you have macy's who already
investigated it
and could vader very easily tell you
that he didn't say the bad word but
again for the millionth time
whether he did or not is immaterial
to the to the criminal aspect of this
case
[Music]
number two so this is weird a few days
ago kelly weil of the daily
daily beast not daily wire um daily
beast
published this piece under the um chaos
debunked heading
and the piece is titled local businesses
love the quote domestic
terror zone in seattle actually
and her point was that in fact all the
businesses in the so-called autonomous
zone in seattle
actually love being in a lawless
hellscape rife with unregulated and
unpunished crime and chaos they love it
that was her whole
she wrote a lengthy piece about it they
really are they can't get enough of it
you know they wake up every morning
tears of joy in their eyes
those tears you see those are of joy
because they look out their shop windows
and see a half-naked man
high on heroin spray-painting a park
bench while protesters
smash the neighbor's window and a
mentally disturbed woman
performs karate with an orange peel over
her face
which is a thing that actually happened
and they think to themselves
i am so glad to be here that's what
kelly weil says anyway but
here's the weird part a report today
from preston phillips local news anchor
in seattle says that a dozen business
owners in the chop zone
are suing they're doing they're filing a
class action lawsuit against the city of
seattle for abandoning them
and leaving them to wallow in the chaos
and filth
that's a that's a strange way to show
you love something isn't it
to file a class-action lawsuit to get it
to stop
hmm number three a black lives matter
activist was on
uh with martha mccallum on fox news last
night a number of crazy things were said
as you can imagine but here's just
one example i just want to put up this
quote from martin luther king and i've
heard you talk about martin luther king
versus malcolm x and you said that he
you know was an anomaly martin luther
king
he said let us be dissatisfied until
that day when nobody will shout white
power when nobody will shout black power
but everybody will talk about god's
power
and human power do you agree with that
i love the lord and my lord and savior
jesus christ is the most famous black
radical revolutionary in history and he
was treated just like
dr king he was uh arrested on occasion
and he was also
crucified or assassinated this is what
happens to
black activists we are killed by the
government
well and if you need context if you read
your bible it'll say
that jesus had feet like burnt brass and
hair like wool i don't
know if you notice but our hair seems to
be more like wool and we seem to be
uh likened to that color than anyone
else and you know it's just the
hypocrisy and the white supremacy in
america and in the world
that would show us portraits of a pasty
white jesus jesus was not white we all
know this
okay no um no
that no that's a no on that one
jesus was a middle eastern jew jew
that's what he was
there's no debate over that he he was a
middle eastern jew he wasn't white he
wasn't black
he wasn't white european and he wasn't
black african
he's a middle eastern jew probably
looked very similar to what middle
eastern jews look like today
if that matters which it doesn't
as to the bible quote the bible verse
quoted there that's not a bible verse
that's just uh he that's that's not
actually the bible
the gospels never once describe any of
christ's physical features
um they don't say a single word about
what he looks like
and there might be a reason for that you
know maybe there's a reason for that
i say that his physical his physical
appearance didn't matter
well i think the writers of the gospels
agreed that's why they don't describe
him
revelation does provide a description
you might say but it's
highly metaphorical and it's describing
a glorified christ
returning on judgment day the actual
verse says
um the hair on his head was white like
wool as white as
snow that's the verse that he mentioned
but he didn't quite quote it that way
did he
now i don't think that means jesus is
white as in caucasian
but it does show that the wool comment
is about color uh the color of the hair
that's what it's about
color of the hair specifically is what
it's referring to
and so all of that is nonsense and
and of course you know this and i've
addressed it before so i'm not going to
go into detail but this constant
constant effort um
by activists and leftists to make jesus
into a into himself sort of a political
activist
who was killed by the government because
they were afraid of his political
message
is just completely off base
there is no support for it whatsoever
no support in the bible now
there is support among new age scholars
who have who have for decades been
trying to turn jesus into that but all
you have to do is pick up the gospels
and read them
he was not a political activist at all
he
he barely discussed anything remotely
political and when he did
you know he said give to caesar what is
caesar's
but that was not jesus's message it was
not one about politics
and the roman government couldn't care
less
about jesus they weren't they weren't
worried about about you know
an itinerant preacher an itinerant
jewish preacher going around talking
about
from their perspective from their
perspective he's just another jewish
preacher there's a lot of them
going around talking about uh jewish you
know theology
they didn't care about that made no
difference to them
they killed jesus pilate ordered the
execution
to appease the mob he didn't care he
tried to
uh you know he tried to exonerate jesus
he said i find no fault in him i don't
see a problem with them kill them
because the mob demanded it
so again this is if there's any um
lesson we can apply to the you know the
current it's
it's that this is why you don't go along
with mob rule
number four bubba wallace has slightly
changed his tune from that embarrassing
cnn performance after the
news story was exposed as false as as
you may remember
um and he he went on
cnn in what was really a
a therapy session more than an interview
and uh was
defiant and basically doubling down on
on the whole story in a lot of ways
although he admitted that it wasn't a
hate crime but he was doubling down
saying it was a noose and trying to
still make himself a victim anyway
yesterday he published a statement well
i don't know if he published it so much
as his pr people finally got to him and
they published this but this is what he
says now it's been an emotional few days
first off i want to say how relieved i
am
that the investigation revealed that
this wasn't what we feared it was i want
to thank my team nascar and the fbi for
acting swiftly and treating this as a
real threat i think we'll gladly take a
little embarrassment over what the
alternatives could have been make no
mistake
though some will try this should not
detract from the show of unity we had on
monday and the progres and the progress
we've made as a sport to be a more
welcoming
environment for all okay that's
slightly less objectionable than his
than his then the spectacle on
uh on monday tuesday night
but what's missing from this an apology
there's no apology how about just
i'm sorry about that there's no
accountability
and he says oh it's it's not what we
feared it was
oh you you just feared that it was that
because that's not what you said bubba
what you said
was that this is a hate crime a
despicable act of hate that's what you
said
you didn't say i fear that it might be a
hate crime
you stated with a for a fact that it is
with not only with no skepticism but
insulting
anyone who was skeptical about it
so and then as far as it shouldn't
detract from the show of unity
well i'm sorry it does detract from the
show of unity
because that was a show of unity based
on a lie
and if we want unity in america we're
not going to find it based on lies
number five here's a great video of a
white protester trying to explain racism
to black cops a black person wanting the
privilege and power is white
yes
we're done my black wife is calling me
out of conversations
it has nothing to do with your
acquaintances
yeah it must have been so intimidating
that all the police moved that way
that's impressive
it's just a little
when you're drawing to have a
conversation you have a one-track mind
there's no way to have that conversation
you gotta you have to be able to
open the whole story all right
racism can only be white systemically
sir
individually it can be a different color
but systemically it could only be white
it's not an example it's not an agenda
it's the past
the present and hopefully not the future
you just know
and great stuff from that officer at the
end there for from all the officers
actually
but you notice how this woman
it really is a cult these people are in
a cult
full-on cult she's just repeating
doctrine
she's like a autonomous autonomaton
a robot can't engage she can't
it's like she can't even hear what
what's being said to her
she's saying what she's trained to say
you could almost you can almost see the
spirals in her eyes like a
like a hypnotized cartoon character
right systemically
you're systemically racist systemically
systemically
what the hell are you babbling about
this is what people on the left they
think that
just saying the word systemically will
wins the argument
all they have to do is say oh really
systemically boom mic drop
got you on that didn't i nothing you
could say in response to that
systemically she's just she's just
shouting the word systemically at him
systemically it's systemic
um you have no idea what you're saying
you have no clue what you're saying
but you're saying it because it's what
you've been trained to say
by the way the officer with the black
wife
and he says you know it starts by saying
okay i'm going to go call my black wife
now try
you know obviously as a as a dig at the
the the woman calling him a racist
and she says that doesn't prove you're
not a racist
yes actually it does it really does
uh i think having a black wife very good
evidence that you're not racist
extremely good i'd say it's almost 100
confirmation
that you're not racist yes
do you know why because despite what
you're what we are told
by these barely coherent activists
who are shouting the word systemically
racism is not some mysterious
undefinable ambiguous thing
it's not i'll tell you what racism is
racism is this if you think
that people of another race are inferior
because of their race you're racist
if you don't you're not
that's it the end that's what racism is
if if you have any opinion outside of
people of this race are inferior because
of the race you're not racist
there might you might still be wrong you
might there are plenty of other
objectionable opinions a person can have
on in you know
in the realm of race or in any other
realm it's not racist though
because that's what racism is
but the left doesn't want us to think
that or know that because
it's a pretty clever trick they know
that if they turn racism
into this impossible to understand
highly sort of academic and scholarly
concept
then they become the gatekeepers and
they get to decide and then
you're no longer able to deny that
you're racist because then they can say
you only think you're not racist but you
actually are because you don't know what
racism is
that's why you constantly have leftists
many times white leftists
trying to lecture you about what racism
is they love doing that
i'll tell you what racism is yeah you
don't know what racism is
you only think you're not racist think
about that statement
think about what a stupid statement that
you only think you're not racist
guess what if you think you're not
racist you're not
because racism is all about what you
think
the hell is that it's like you know if i
think
um that uh you know
that i don't like vanilla ice cream then
i don't like it
it's simple as that it's about what i
think it comes down to what you think
all of these issues are about what you
think how you feel that's what it is
so if you think you're not bigoted in a
certain area then you're not if you
think you're not racist towards a
certain group of people you're not
because it just that's what it's all and
you know something else
you are the only person who can speak to
it
you're the only person who can decide
whether or not you're racist
nobody else can because no one else can
see inside your head
i mean you could certainly lie about it
but in terms of
who who who is the one single absolute
authority
on your racism or lack thereof you
whether you speak honestly on the
subject or not is a different subject
but you're the only authority not some
other person
not some leftist in a surgical mask
holding a sign at a blm rally
shouting at you they're not an authority
they don't know a single damn thing
about what you think or what's
in your head
all right now we're going to move on to
um
to our daily cancellation before we do
if you're not already a daily wire
member you should consider
getting a reader's pass to dailywire.com
it's a great value for only three bucks
a month and if you sign up you get that
first month for only 99 cents you also
get access to our mobile app
articles ad free access to exclusive
editorials
like the latest one that i wrote about
the bubble wall situation specifically
focusing on the fact that
the fbi sent 15 federal agents to
investigate a rope in a garage
while there's anarchy and insurrection
in the streets so i
talked about that analyze that you can
check that out uh if you haven't gotten
a reader's pass already go to
dailywire.com and sign up for just a
buck okay
now for our daily cancellation the
actress jenny slate has apologized for
her
flawed decision to voice a non-white
character
on the netflix show big mouth slate
announced that she's stepping aside from
the role
she acknowledged that her initial
decision to to voice the animated
character was a symptom of her quote
white privilege
and she explained that she originally
thought it was okay because
her character missy has a white jewish
mother
um but but and she is white and jewish
so she thought okay i can
but she now understands that she could
only take on that role because of quote
unjust allowances made within a system
of societal white supremacy
and she makes a salient point of course
because it's well known that the
ultimate goal of any nazi or clan member
is to be a voice actor for a mixed-race
cartoon character
this this is the goal right of white
supremacy is uh
it's very i don't mean to laugh it's
very serious slate promised to do her
part
to fight the white supremacist scourge
by quote engaging in meaningful
anti-racist action and she expressed
deep remorse for anyone that she may
have quote hurt
by doing voiceovers on a cartoon show
if you were somehow hurt in some way
by the fact that jenny slate was doing a
voiceover on a netflix cartoon show
she's sorry for that she really is
as a person who was hurt by it um
i'm i'm glad that she is it means a lot
to me
i you know i was waking up every morning
distraught over jenny slate's character
on the show big
big mouth on netflix it was ruining my
life
it was the only thing i could think
about finally i have some closure
on the same day actress kristen bell
stepped aside from her her role
voicing a non-white character named
molly on the animated show central park
which i don't even know existed until
now she apologized for her quote lack of
awareness of her quote pervasive
privilege
she admitted that quote casting a
mixed-race character with a white
actress
undermines the specificity of the mixed
race and black american experience
now it's not clear how a cartoon
character's voice
could undermine anyone's experience
or even what it means to undermine an
experience
but whatever it means and however it
happens the point is that kristen bell
is very sorry
and she wants you to know that she's not
one of the she's not one of the bad
inherently racist white people she's one
of the good
inherently racist white people um
in the twitter thread that where she
posted this this statement
the very humble kristen bell responded
to a person thanking her for the
statement
and for her decision to step aside and
she responded by saying you know
quote i don't deserve a thank you and
she said that
she quote deserves to acknowledge my
part in the problem and then rectify it
and this was an impressive answer i
thought because it goes to show that
in no way whatsoever did kristen bell
come to this racial enlightenment at
this particular moment in time
and dramatically announced that
enlightenment to the entire world in a
public forum
because she wanted applause and approval
in no way in no way
was that what this was about certainly
not
no no no no no don't don't don't don't
be cynical about this okay
now i personally find these decisions by
bell and slate to be inspiring and so
inspiring
that the last thing i'm going to do is
cancel them you thought i was about to
cancel them didn't you
that's because you're a bigot and that's
your own inherent privilege and pride
and uh and white supremacy talking okay
in fact i'd like to build statues in
their honor so that protesters can
promptly tear them down and the women
themselves i'm sure will join in tearing
them down because that's how
relentlessly progressive they are
instead of canceling them i would like
to suggest other characters that should
be canceled
along similar lines so i want to i want
to kind of
build off of their the steps that
they've taken
and suggest some other characters as
well so um obviously darth vader
has to go he's a white man in a black
suit
voiced by a black man i'm not sure how
that's racist but i'm sure that it must
be
somehow bart simpson is a boy voiced by
an adult woman
now for years uh i accepted this
problematic dichotomy because i assumed
that the simpson was headed
simpsons was headed in a direction for a
story arc where the young bart would
discover his
inner female identity and come out as
transgender and begin hormone therapy
but you know after 30 years on the air
this moment still has not arrived and
i'm beginning to despair that the
simpsons
will not ever uh make the expected
transition into a nuanced introspective
drama
about the experiences of transgender
adolescents in modern america
and because of that i think we have to
get rid of that character too other
characters that should be canceled
abolished outlawed
uh imprisoned executed or at least
recast
are perhaps maybe a little bit less
obvious but i think still
still crucial to defeating white
supremacy so let's go through a few of
these
e.t from the movie e.t
only a few lines of dialogue in the
movie which is a problem in and of
itself but
those lines are handled by a white voice
actress named patricia welsh
it boggles my mind
that in the entire cosmos
populated by a hundred billion galaxies
with a hundred billion stars in each of
them and trillions of planets
steven spielberg could not find even one
actual extraterrestrial
to take on this role you mean to tell me
in the entire universe you couldn't find
one
a white actor cannot empathize with the
lived reality of aliens
um certainly not enough to capture the
fullness and depth
of their experiences on screen it really
is as simple as that
we have to remember something okay
acting
is not about pretending to be something
you're not
that's not what it is acting in an ideal
society
would consist of people being themselves
and doing and saying all the same sort
of stuff they would do and say on a
normal day so
in a truly progressive culture films
would have no characters
no script no plot
no actors no directors
instead the audience would just watch
people all of them non-white of course
going about their day running errands
sitting on the couch
checking the mailbox preparing dinner et
cetera and that's what it would be
that's all the film would be every film
would be like this
all of them would be titled experiences
and all of them would win every oscar
every year
the fact that this scenario i just
concocted in my head
is not a reality just proves that white
supremacy is real and literal nazis are
running the country
another bigoted film that must be
eradicated or changed immediately would
be a disturbing fascist manifesto
from 1987 called the brave little
toaster
now the film tells the story of
appliances led by the titular toaster
who embark on a quest to find their
owner now
there are a number of obvious problems
here not the least of which being the
deeply insensitive reference to owners
which brings to mind the legacy of
slavery but more to the point
none of the characters not toaster
not lampy not blanky not radio
not kirby the vacuum are voiced by
actual household appliances
and it is difficult enough for toasters
to find work in hollywood
already as it is if they're not even
allowed to play toasters
how are they supposed to get a foothold
in the industry that's my question
similar problems can be found in the
film babe um where the protagonist pig
is not portrayed
by an authentic pig boss baby a film in
which alec baldwin
ruthlessly appropriates the lived
experiences and identity of actual
toddlers
um well of course he does act like a
toddler much much of the time but but
he's not a real one a nightmare before
christmas a movie about undead humans
that exclusively casts
alive humans the the 90s nickelodeon
cartoon hey arnold okay which features a
person with a
normal shaped head voicing a character
with a grotesquely deformed head
a casting decision that still rankles
the grotesquely deformed head community
to this day
gdh for short many other examples can be
provided
the point is that a great many films and
television shows arguably
all of them have for decades featured
actors playing characters that are in
some way different from their real
selves
this has to end and it has to end today
kristen bell and jenny slate have helped
take the first step
we have to have the courage to go all
the way
and until that happens all movies and
all shows
and everyone who watches them are
canceled
and we'll leave it there a lot to think
about and meditate on
which is what i will go do right now
thanks for watching and godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clavin
[Music]